the longest-serving Democrat the
longest-serving senator really in
American history was a former KKK
recruiter called Robert Byrd when Byrd
who was from West Virginia died was just
in 2010 then President Barack Obama
heaped praise on his memory
Ralph northern by contrast does not
occupy an essential Senate seat in a
battleground state he could be replaced
tomorrow by an even more reliable
lieutenant governor therefore Democrats
are demanding that he resigned
immediately watch the litany he needs to
resign immediately to stop the pain in
Virginia and frankly around the nation I
think that the governor should resign
he's lost the authority the government
he has to resign I think he should
resign
now should he resign yes he should step
down and start his road to redemption he
should resign so disturbing so racist
there's no place for racism in our
government so far be it for this show to
defend Ralph Northern and to be clear
who would put that kind of garbage on
out of your book page but it does
nevertheless raise the question when is
it okay to forgive the mistakes of
others
Zaid Jilani is a journalist he's a man
of the left over the weekend he tried to
answer that question in an insightful
essay he wrote for quill at he put it
this way quote we've all done things
were not proud of in our past and our
most offensive and obnoxious moments do
not encapsulate our lives but given an
American elite culture that is
regressing to a secular version of old
puritanical norms whereby sinners are
branded for life and there are political
points to be scored for casting them
into Hellfire it is not surprising that
northern was immediately deluged with
calls to resign
say Johnny joins us tonight the story
thanks very much for coming on yeah
great to be here so the the reason I
love this essay and I assume we don't
agree on anything politically but I
thought you made a very fair point in
that you know when can we forgive
someone in American politics now is that
impossible is everyone have to lie
because they can't be forgiven I mean I
think one of the things that our ancient
traditions our ancient religions and
science agree on is that people's
behaviors and attitudes don't stay the
chain don't stay the same over time
yeah people change dramatically over
time they certainly Saints dramatically
five years nobody is alleged that Ralph
Northam has done anything as a physician
or as a public sermon that is in any way
bigoted or racist so why is a snapshot
of his life from 35 years ago being used
to totally encapsulate who this man is
it's totally irrational and by the left
jumping on on this bandwagon I'm calling
to resign they're undermining their own
philosophy how can they say criminal
justice reform in one breath
say that we need to let murderers and
rapists and batterers and robbers out of
prison early which I agree with by the
way I do agree that they deserve a
second chance and they should be
rehabilitated but they say that someone
who did something offensive obnoxious
stupid and racist one time in their life
should therefore be barred from
political office no matter what he's
done in the rest of his life it doesn't
make any sense and these Democratic
politicians are being totally
unprincipled so you actually had an
example I wish out in front of me in the
piece of a felon who was going on to run
for office after getting out and this
was an argue against it but approved of
by the left is an example of redemption
yeah I mean this man in Texas actually
knife to another man to death he killed
a man and a number of left wingers said
it's great that he's running for office
now because he shows that someone can
turn their life around redeem themselves
and by the way I don't disagree with
that but the left at the same time has
gone after north and it's gone after 15
year-old teenagers on the mall who may
have made one or two offensive gestures
they're trying to destroy individuals
instead of looking at the structures
that are creating much stronger and much
more destructive behaviors one out of
three black children in the state of
Virginia are living in poverty why isn't
that the national crisis why isn't that
national emergency why is it photo in a
yearbook from 35 years ago the emergence
exactly well maybe because they don't
feel like changing the structures that
are destroying children honestly a lot
of them don't honestly that's the truth
I've worked in and around the Democratic
Party for a long time I don't think a
lot of them are can fit are convinced
that that's the main priority so they
focus instead as you point out in the
piece on symbolic crimes rather than
actual crimes or crises because the
reality is okay for instance Kirsten
Gillibrand was one of the people who
called for north and to resign she was a
corporate lawyer for Philip Morris for
four years when the Clinton
administration was suing them suing big
tobacco
she helped an industry that killed
millions of people and she's out here
saying that what Ralph Northam did was
it was a stupid racist prank when he was
like a medical student is inexcusable
and she was someone who didn't just do
something symbolic Iran
she defended an industry was actually
killing people if we actually focus on
the substance of policy these are the
people who should be resigning or at
least apologizing and making amends
which is what Ralph Northam is doing now
which we should do but he should not
resign because it would create a
terrible nor him we'd be searching the
tweets and the Facebook Likes of every
kid for 20 years trying to find
something raised to trying to ruin their
lives which is not the way forward he
should make amends he should apologize
to African Americans and then he should
pursue policy to improve their lives
that's what he should do you were
welcome on this show any time thank you
for that thank you I appreciate it